on va analyser tout ce dossier avec
jennifer un coin aider les professeurs
de droit à l'université d'ottawa experte
en responsabilité pénale des entreprises
les dans nos studios de tahoua merci
d'être là madame quid bonsoir alors tout
au long de cette saga snc-lavalin disait
pourtant vouloir se défendre plaider non
coupable est ce que ça vous surprend ce
revirement
les règlements en matière criminelle
arrive souvent dans des circonstances
qui nous surprend mais il faut regarder
le contexte plus large
on vient d'avoir des condamnations sur
tous les chefs d'accusation contre un
cadre de l'entreprise
monsieur bah oui l'entreprise a quand
même envie de tourner la page
et donc même si bien sûr on souhaite
dans un monde idéal pouvoir se défendre
devant un tribunal et aboutir avec un
acquittement bien sûr si l'occasion
arrive d'accomplir largement les mêmes
objectifs
en concluant un accord je pense que
c'est normal qu'on va explorer cette
possibilité
le fait que ce soit une filiale qui
plaide coupable et non la société mère
qu'est ce que ça change pour
l'entreprise madame queen
mais c'est sûr à ce moment là
l'entreprise le groupe
la maison mère elle n'a pas de
condamnation associé à son nom et donc
c'est une autre personne morale qui
plaide coupable
on peut dire que il ya toujours une
certaine tâche parce que c'est une
finale dans le même groupe mais sur le
plan juridique le sensei le groupe n'a
pas de condamnation c'est quand même
important
mais l'accusation qui a été retenue pour
le plaidoyer a également été conçue de
sorte à ce que ce soit pas une
infraction qui provoque la
disqualification en île bagne plaidoyer
de culpabilité pour fraude plutôt que
pour corruption qu'est ce que ça change
concrètement c'est important parce que
dans un monde où
une bonne proportion des pays ont adhéré
à des conventions anti corruption et
notamment les pays de l' ocde dans le
cadre de la convention de l'oecd eux il
ya une sorte de reconnaissance entre ces
pays là que des infractions pour des
crimes qui sont directement liés à la
corruption notamment la corruption des
agents publics étrangers seraient des
motifs de disqualification bon on peut
pas se prononcer de manière définitive
par rapport à tous les régimes de
disqualification dans le monde qui
aurait peut-être quand même certaines
nuances et peut-être des différences
mais c'est sûr qu'en plaidant coupable à
une infraction de fraude
on a on minimise cette possibilité de
disqualification dans notre régime parce
que l'enjeu ici c'est d'avoir accès à de
grands contrats d'infrastructures que ce
soit au canada ou à l'international donc
là on lève les obstacles
oui absolument et en fait je dirais que
probablement cessé sur le plan
international que c'est plus important
parce qu'au canada la proportion des
contrats publics est moindre que ça l'a
déjà été je pense en partie en raison de
l'incertitude qui pesait toujours sur le
sort du dossier oui est-ce que c'est
sale et madame coûts et d'une amende de
280 millions est ce que c'est justifié
dans les circonstances ah ben voilà la
question
malheureusement j'étais pas en salle de
cours j'ai pas entendu les commentaires
des procureurs au soutien de cette
amende
c'est sûr que le chiffre est important
il fait très important j'ai pas fait de
comparaison avec toutes les autres
amants mais c'est sûr que c'est très
très important mais en soit le chiffre
eux-mêmes ne communiquait pas beaucoup
faut comprendre le pourquoi et moi j'ai
toujours pas entendu une description
un décorticage de comment on est arrivé
à ce chiffre
qu'est ce que ça représente et je pense
si on espère avoir un effet dissuasif ou
un effet pédagogique de cette amende
pour apprendre aux autres ce qu'on
devrait ne devrait pas faire et vous
attention aux conséquences il faut quand
même avoir un certain argumentaire au
soutien du chiffre oui parce que là
c'est une entente en fait est ce que la
cour pourrait se prononcer pour est est
ce que c'est une formalité l'approbation
tout ça pourrait être bloquée ou
modifiées par le tribunal
dans ce que si d'après ce que j'ai
compris c'est une soumission conjointe
sur sentence
dans ce contexte là en droit canadien ce
genre de proposition conjointe doit être
respectée à défaut d'avoir des
indications que sade est considéré
l'administration de la justice ce qui
est un seuil très élevé alors en
principe de tribunaux elle va
l'entériner
on parle de probation pour trois ans
surveillance d'un contrôleur indépendant
est ce que c'est contraignant ça dans la
mesure où c'est une ordonnance de
probation qui étant terminée par un
tribunal c'est une ordonnance de la cour
est donc il faut la respecter sous peine
d'outragé ou de non-respect d'une
ordonnance mais la question à savoir
c'est encore le détail
j'ai vu dans le communiqué de presse de
la compagnie on est décrit en terme
général qu'est ce qu'on entend faire
mais encore une fois j'aimerais voir
vraiment exactement ce à quoi on s'est
engagé parce que si on veut parler de
conformité ou non conformité avec un
ordonnance de probation il faut
connaître le détail alors oui ça
pourrait c'est contraignant mais encore
une fois que ce à quoi on s'attendait à
quoi est-ce qu'on s'engage c'est
important de communiquer sur clairement
est-ce que c'est mieux d'avoir obtenu ce
règlement cette amende que d'avoir eu
une accord de réparation par exemple
pour snc lavalin pour snc-lavalin je
pense que c'est du règlement lui donne
les mêmes les mêmes conséquences qu'on
cherchait c'est à dire d'éviter la
disqualification de mettre un terme à
ces accusations qui traîne depuis
longtemps et qui bien sûr ont nui à
l'entreprise au niveau réputationnel
niveau de sa capacité de soumissionner
mais du point de vue de l'intérêt public
je pense que je suis pas persuadé encore
que c'est nécessairement le mérite mais
c'est le règlement qu'on a
oui absolument merci beaucoup madame
couette pour vos explications merci à
vous bonsoir